it's time for scene and unseen when we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
of that we turn to Fox News contributor
Raymond Arroyo um Raymond I know you
have a special new addition to the show
tonight
I do you know Disneyland Laura has an
attraction called Great Moments with Mr
Lincoln well tonight we're unveiling our
own reoccurring attraction Great Moments
with Mrs Harris what is it that you have
on your mind when you wake up every
morning our democracy
where if I think everything is at stake
right now one day some young lady
is going to look at your picture the way
you look at Thurgood and John Lewis
picture what do you hope they look at
and say I hope they say that
um
they should that they will say I can do
anything I will not be burdened by what
has been I will believe in what can be
Laura they're going to look at that
image and say Here's a woman who was
pulling at two percent Who Rose to the
highest office in the land and also a
woman who now her entire party is trying
to throw off the ticket because she
can't summon a crowd she's a loser sorry
no no it's just
I'm still trying to get over the graphic
for the new attraction all right what
else I also like the how you like the
hang time on that answer from Kamala
Harris well uh I think uh anyway there
was there was one point in the Sharpton
interview that was quite Illuminating
watch this are you concerned about
turnout especially among blacks uh in
the election I
am always concerned about turnout it
takes an effort
to turn out to vote
people have things to do
and if there's no Coalition there's no
victory for any of us we all
have a common purpose and a common
destiny
and so let's do this together all right
oh my God Coalition is in trouble well
Harrison the river worried because black
voters are abandoning the Democratic
party that new Reuters poll I don't know
if you saw this 18 18 of black voters
said they would vote for Donald Trump
and black men are now speaking out
listen to this I think he's done more
for America and people who are like not
well off then a lot of presidents see
Biden was sneaky he used Camilla Harris
Camilla Harris Don't Care About Us he
just you know what I'm saying he's sold
I'm picking Tron I voted for Biden so I
think voting for the promises and you
know a lot that he said I don't see a
lot of that right now
these black voters are not stupid Laura
and it's this is you've been reporting
on this for weeks the economy touches
their lives first and foremost so does
crime the gas prices the grocery prices
they can't sit still for this and just
say oh I'm a Democrat for life they made
back they may have a little special
message for the Democrats this year
we'll see
well I'm just I'm just glad that you
brought us this idea that turnout
requires turning out an effort Raymond
thank goodness Kamala cleared that up
for us my mother as everybody knows I've
said this many times but she was a
waitress until her early 70s
she went on Election Day she worked her
tail off went on Election Day she didn't
have to do absentee because we didn't go
anywhere so on Election Day she voted
this idea that it's a Herculean effort
to vote is ridiculous get yourself to
the polls if you care about the country
or vote vote absentee if you have to
finally Laura even though the president
is out of sight as you reported earlier
he's not out of mind former Senator
Scott Brown is revealing what really
happened when Joe Biden swore him in
when you got sworn in as Senator was he
like hair sniffing Gail or handy with
Gail or did I imagine yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I told him
I told him to stop he didn't act the way
I thought he should and and you know we
called him on it and you know that's it
now Laura we had our producers pull the
video look at this he does get awfully
friendly and handsy with Mrs Brown there
we may have to start a new segment great
gropes with Mr Biden
oh great sniffs it's either sniffing or
nibbling or he's he's in your aura space
for way too long remember Raymond when
we saw him at that party in Washington
and he grabbed my shoulders that time
but there was a moment we wrote about it
and I don't know which book but it was
yeah it was he likes to put those hands
on your shoulders Laura I thought I
thought I didn't know what he was going
to do to you and and what did he say uh
Ingram Eric's favorite yeah that God's
honest truth God's honest truth you're
my favorite of all the right wing
crazies it was actually a pretty funny
one it was actually good for buying it
wasn't bad but you know he does he he
has instinctive a desire to touch Every
Woman around him I just I mean it's just
he's a he's a he's he's very touching
he's maybe he's that's his compassion
just coming right out here it may be
time it may be time for the leash I
think you know to keep him back from the
women and to get him off stage at the
proper time would be a good thing no I'm
poor baby all right Raymond great see
you thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else